en nuestro vídeo pasado habíamos visto
esta ecuación diferencial que en un caso
particular de las ecuaciones
diferenciales de segundo orden ya
habíamos propuesto que iguala a la x
como solución de esta ecuación
diferencial particular para esto nos
dimos cuenta que no se quedaban por el
negro característico el cual no podíamos
factorizar y sacar dos raíces si no me
creen sería muy bueno que ustedes lo
hicieran para probar que realmente no me
haya equivocado y hasta aquí llegamos a
una solución general que tenía que ver
con dos constantes y que tenían que ver
también con las raíces del pueblo muy
característico en esta ocasión lo que
quiero a ver es cómo poder hacer para
sacar las constantes si tengo
condiciones iniciales pero este pizarrón
está hecho un caos entonces lo que voy a
hacer es bajar el pizarrón para que se
vea todo más ordenado y voy a reescribir
otra vez la función con la que partimos
es decir y eb y prima más se acuerdan
eran cinco veces y en prima
+ 6 bien y esto lo teníamos igualado a
cero lo voy a poner así para que todo
quede muy claro y ahora sí le voy a
poner condiciones iniciales voy a decir
que ya de cero va a ser igual a dos en
este caso y fíjense muy bien voy a decir
que prima de cero en este caso va a ser
igual a tres estoy tomando dos
condiciones iniciales una que tienen que
ver con mi función evaluada en el punto
cero y otra que tiene que ver con la
derivada de mi función evaluar en el
punto cero y así voy a poder encontrar
estas dos constantes que me hacen falta
bien entonces cómo voy a poder sacar
esas dos constantes pues primero voy a
evaluar en cero desde cero es igual a 2
por lo que sabíamos de las condiciones
iniciales y ahora sí si sustituyó a x
por 0 pues me queda
al menos 2 por 0 que pues es 1 y x
segundo pues me queda solamente c1 y c2
por la menos tres por cero pues menos
tres por cero cero y el acero es 1 y me
queda entonces ese 2 muy parecido al
caso anterior
se dan cuenta esto lo voy a atrapar de
otro color porque es una ecuación que
tiene que ver con c1 y c2 solamente
ahora voy a utilizar mi segunda
condición inicial que dice prima de 0 es
igual a 3 entonces voy a derivar mi
función de x y que me va a quedar 10
prima de x es igual a si yo recuerdo
como se deriva una exponencial pues se
bajaba la constante y me quedan menos 2
x c 1 por el ala menos 2 x esto era por
la regla de la cadena se acuerdan y bien
de manera muy parecido me va a quedar
para el segundo término me va a quedar
menos 13 2 por ea la menos 3 x ok pero
yo lo que realmente quería era la
función derivada evaluada en 0 entonces
voy a evaluar en x 0 y me va a quedar
menos 12 1 por la 0 pero ya la 01
entonces pues elimina y me queda menos
13 2 por ella la 0 de manera muy
parecida y entonces se elimina bien
entonces ya tengo en la ecuación menos
1 13 2 que s prima evaluada en 0 pero
por otra parte yo tenía que ir primer
balance no era 3 y entonces ya tengo
otra ecuación que tienen que ver con c1
y c2 la voy a tratar de otro color pero
miren he creado ahora dos ecuaciones que
tienen que ver tanto con c 1 como 11 2
es decir un sistema de ecuaciones los
voy a escribir aquí para que se vea más
claro c1 c2 igualados y por otra parte
de la ecuación número 2 voy a tener
menos 12 1 por menos 3 c 2
está escrito todo en la ecuación número
2 esto es igual a 3 están de acuerdo
ok y este sistema de ecuaciones lo voy a
resolver por suma y resta voy a
multiplicar la primera actuación por 2
para que se elimine con la segunda y
también voy a cambiar al color azul
entonces me va a quedar 12 1 más 12 2 y
esto es igual a 2 por 2 que es 4 y si yo
sumo esta ecuación y esta ecuación menos
12 1 más 12 1 pues se cancela
- 13 212 2 me quedan menos de dos y tres
más 4 es igual a 7 o dicho de otra
manera si yo paso el signo del otro lado
pues me queda que ese 2 es igual a menos
7 perfecto se dan cuenta ya tengo la
primer constante más aún si yo sustituyó
en la primera ecuación me queda que sea
uno menos 7 menos 7 porque era hace dos
es igual a 9
2017 es igual a 2 jajaja me estoy
equivocando para ver si me están
poniendo atención bueno en fin
pero aquí está el 9 fíjense c 1 si lo
pasó del otro lado le quedan dos más 7 x
9 aquí está el 9 del que le estaba
hablando y ésta no estaba tan perdido y
bien ya tengo la constante 1 y la
constante 2 y entonces ya puedo yo
sustituir en ecuación tiene x la cual es
una solución particular de resolución
original dado que ya tengo las
condiciones iniciales entonces que les
quede x pues se uno que vale 9 por el
ala menos 2 x más de 2 pero se 2 valía
menos 7 entonces me va a quedar menos 7
y a la menos 3 x y esta es una solución
particular de la solución general que
teníamos arriba pero ya sabía yo mis
condiciones iniciales entonces ésta sí
es mi solución particular de esta
ecuación diferencial
en el siguiente vídeo voy a ver otro
ejemplo y lo voy a analizar con mucho
cuidado así que nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo